mr d'avoir cédé face à sierre tu
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le ministre au lendemain des
attentats à paris du 13 novembre les
enquêteurs ne disposent qu'une piste
pour détecter le terroriste about seul
seul un témoignage va permettre de
localiser de neutraliser ce témoignage
il émane d'une femme courageuse que nous
appellerons sonia qui sait que cet acte
va transformer sa vie car elles
témoignent sous sa propre identité et
donc cela les expose à la connaissance
de tous
dès lors cette jeune femme n'a plus
qu'une solution se cacher se protéger si
une surveillance policière lui a bien
été accordé elle apparaît vite comme
insuffisantes et surtout on ne lui
apporte aucune aide matérielle ni aucune
aide psychologique pour elle tout est
dans deux mots peur et solitude subi il
a fallu semble-t-il que sony a décidé de
sortir de sa solitude et accorde à une
grande chaîne d'information continue une
interview où on ne la reconnaît pas pour
que vos services prennent la juste
mesure du danger et renforcent la
surveillance et du offre une aide
psychologique alors monsieur le ministre
pas d'esprit polémique d'autant que
votre gouvernement vient de présenter un
texte qui semble répondre aux
problématiques du statut de témoins
notamment sur la protection de son
identité
le rapprochant ainsi du statut du
repenti il n'en demeure pas moins que
d'ici l'adoption de ces dispositions
il faut qu'un code de bonne pratique
donne à mon service les moyens de
protéger des témoins clés dans des
affaires aussi dramatique dans cette
période monsieur le ministre que comptez
vous faire
merci témoins coupe la parole est à mme
bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le député dans la
responsabilité qui est la mienne j'ai un
devoir c'est de ne pas évoquer
publiquement ce qu'est l'action de mes
services y compris lorsque elle est
injustement décriée dès lors que cette
action rendue publique est de nature à
mettre gravement en danger la vie d'un
témoin c'est la raison pour laquelle je
ne me suis jamais exprimé sur ce sujet
je sais parfaitement le décalage qui
existe entre ce qui est dit et ce qui a
été fait et je mesure par conséquent la
dimension d'injustice qui s'attache à
certaines polémiques pour ne pas évoquer
certaines manipulations
mais la responsabilité qui est la mienne
et sur ce sujet de garder le silence
pourquoi parce que cette personne a été
auditionné sous l'autorité du parquet
antiterroriste que après qu'elle a été
auditionné dans le respect rigoureux des
procédures de droit puisque vous savez
que pour qu'un paiement d'un témoin soit
auditionné sous x il faut qu'au moment
où l'audition on soit assurée kinésique
aucun lien entre ce témoin et l' affaire
concernait ce que généralement on sait
après donc pour toutes ces raisons là
nous avons pris des dispositions
et j'en ai le détail et s'il faut rendre
compte un jour je le ferai bien entendu
devant ce dont c'est le rôle que de
savoir qui nous ont conduits à protéger
cette personne et au delà
il n'existe pas en france malgré
l'éviction prise par la loi perben ii
dispositions qui permettent de financer
les repentis nous avons pris les
dispositions pour se faire dans la loi
du 13 novembre
et pour ce qui concerne les témoin il
n'existe actuellement aucun statut qui
permettent d'assurer leur protection de
l'environnement c'est la raison pour
laquelle le garde des sceaux présentera
des dispositions qui permettront de
combler ce vide juridique
pour le reste je renvoie chacun à sa
responsabilité mais voici